[Music]
we're just dancing along to the music
here our own cooking confidence coach
nanny bubby is back in studio thanks to
chapman automotive the sponsors of the
segment today we are learning how to
make roasted french radishes and i'm
very excited because everything is pink
i love it yes and these are beautifully
pink they're kind of rosy uh red but
they're actually called french breakfast
radishes
and what's interesting about it is that
they serve them in your when you're in
paris when you're enjoying they come out
with a soft boiled egg a croissant and
these beautiful french breakfast
radishes but i am also serving them
tonight at a dinner party as a vegetable
so we'll do a little bit of both so the
first thing that we want to do jillian
is we want to steam them which i've done
right here in our beautiful pink pot
i love how everything's coordinated they
just look so cute in this pink pot okay
so they're steamed already and the
reason that we've done that is to
hydrate them just enough so that they
don't dehydrate and shrivel up into the
oven when we start roasting them at a
high temperature about 375 degrees for
about 25 minutes okay and then what
we're going to do very easily is some of
them like these right here which are a
little bit bigger
we're going to slice them in half and
notice that we're keeping the leaves on
because they're just so sexy with the
leaves on so we'll do a little something
fun yes we'll do a little bit of them um
just hole like this and then the rest of
them will you know just see as they come
we'll say oh that looks you know bigger
smaller this should probably be cut and
we're just going to do a smattering of
all different kinds right onto the
platter so so it's okay to leave some of
them full and then the bigger ones do
you think that looks like one that we
should cut out i think we can cut it
yeah
and um okay so there we go okay and then
we'll just take the rest of them out
and we'll just put them on here just for
the benefit of our tv audience to keep
things moving right love it we can do
one or two different ways of putting oil
on them and a little bit of salt and
pepper okay and that would be either we
could throw them into the bowl and we
could toss them with our hands and get
you know salt pepper and our hands get
very very dirty but in this case because
they're so delicate what i love to do is
just spray it on i like a spray it makes
it easy it does and it keeps it off your
hands and you know everywhere else and
then a little bit now here is the nanny
bubby tidbit for the day are you ready
i'm ready when you are salting anything
you always want to hold your hand up as
high as you possibly can okay because
you get the most even
sprinkling when you're high up when you
when you put it low you get these globs
of salt and then globs of pepper do we
have time for a little pepper here we
always got time for pepper
and especially with pepper you don't
want a big glob of pepper so as high up
as you can
and that sounded like a song didn't my
voice smell like it was singing
and then a little smattering of pepper
okay i'm liking this this is very easy
it is really easy and it's beautiful so
we would take these and put them in the
oven at 375 but i'm going to hand them
to you i'll let you put them right over
there and here are some
gloves so you don't burn your hand if
you want to take out what was what's in
the oven okay and you will see they are
beautiful and roasted and caramelized
and golden brown and the stems
dehydrate up and come really really
crispy and it's beautiful so look at
that they smell good yeah how long did
we cook these for about 20 to 25 minutes
depending on your oven at 375 degrees
you can just put them right there
okay and so we'll just slide right down
over here and we're going to plate these
up just on and you'll see on a white
platter and do you see how rosy these
have gotten
these look amazing and they smell so
good and you're right i love the way you
know the green kind of tops it off and
gives it a nice cup of coffee so sexy
with the leaves on it like i see these
you know
with pierre in paris
with a soft boiled egg and a croissant
it's just already thank you
like that and i don't know pierre by the
way
we have about less than a minute left
but i have a quick question for you
since you said you were serving these
for dinner what is something good to
pair them with well i'm pairing this
with a tarragon chicken which i think is
pretty easy and also a vegetable pasta
dish but i always like to have a
separate vegetable off to the side and i
just think this is going to be great and
we're going to take these and we are
going to if you just want to hold that
up yes i will so the camera gets a nice
good shot of that and we're going to
just put a little smattering of french
sea salt right over the top and then we
are ready to say go out and spread love
like butter i love like better than
anybody thank you so much i can't wait
to try these again i'm loving all the
pink thanks for always showing us the
best recipes check out nanny bubby's
kitchen and garden on social media and
online at nannybubby.com we also want to
thank chapman automotive for sponsoring
the segment las vegas now we'll be right
back